foreign
we're going to talk about Nicholas
sturgeon turning into a transphobic
bigger yeah she refuses to put this Isla
gram into a women's prison where she
belongs with her penis yes exactly she's
got a penis and it belongs in a women's
prison exactly why Nicola sturgeon is
refusing her right and an opportunity to
be there and do her thing do what she's
best at exactly sexually assaulting
women yes other women I should say right
because trans women are women but for
some reason for instance they've decided
not to put her her in a women's prison
which I think is bigger Trends it is it
shines phobic if trans women are women
and that is the blankets it's a fact
yeah well it's a fact it's a biological
fact a biological fact I mean it's not
because we've all done GCSE biology but
shut your mouth
trans women are women well said strong
argument exactly which is basically what
what the argument is is shut your mouth
trans women or women correct so that
being the case I
God bless her uh the facial tattooed uh
she does seem blessed by God yeah in
more ways than one exactly sex offender
self yeah right let's not hold that
against her yeah I mean she's just a
rapist yeah right a double rapist double
rapist right I mean who hasn't been
there exactly I mean not most of us but
you know what I mean I mean we were in
an industry where actually yeah I mean
quite a lot of them about yeah but no
you see my point is I'm sure it's the
fault of this the heteronormative CIS
patriarchy exactly that this woman yeah
had to resort to sexually assaulting
other women with her penis no but
actually what's very interesting is that
uh they assaulted they raped women as a
man right and then because they were
suffering from gender dysphoria and well
it's toxic masculinity made them take a
sexual offender yeah and then yeah
gender does foray kicked in it's
particularly when they were in court
yeah and suddenly they saw the courtroom
and then they just had a big dose of
gender dysphoria I mean it does seem to
trigger it doesn't it yeah it does and
and all sudden uh Adam became Isla and
he was just oh no no no no no no no
not bad she wrong yes identified as a
woman yeah and as a result could not be
put in a male prison yeah and in fact
one of the pro one of the I think her
defend the lawyer defending her said
that if we accept that she is
transitioning that goes a long way
towards vindicating her of the crime of
rape exactly uh by the way I do actually
have to say I think nadims of Harvey is
Mr trick here yeah because like we just
talked about at the moment you you know
you face some kind of penalty agenda
dysphoria can kick in I'm sure he
experienced it yeah he probably stuffed
it down because of his internalized
transphobia but he had come out as trans
I do think that would have given him a
better opportunity to defend himself
against the allegations yeah exactly
that's what he needed to do yeah that's
what he still needs to do plus he's a
slapping so he'd look better come on
Nadia stop pretending to be the demon
exactly there you go so
interesting time send us your Super Chat
send us your paypals Anton with gloss
over it there are people who are
wondering why this beautiful woman is
refused entry into a female prison but
let's in the words of the paper boys
from bygone era let's read all about it
uh trans racist Isla Bryson Ah that's a
different name she's got anyway well if
you're going to change names you might
as well change them
oh you know we're not fact-based that's
why it says uncensored unfiltered
uninformed at the top so we may have got
a name wrong yeah which is obviously
transphobic but we got her gender right
unlike Nicholas sturgeon yeah uh
transference Isla Bryson won't stay in
women's prison Nicholas sturgeon says
Bryson is being held in isolation at a
women's jail before sentencing because
that's what you want transgender woman
convicted of rape this week will not
serve her sentence in Scotland's only
all-female prison Nicholas sturgeon has
said Isla Bryson 31 is understood to be
a waiting sentencing at a segregation
unit at Quantum Vale women's prison
Sterling she committed the crimes in
2016 and 2019 before her gender
transition
she found guilty on Tuesday and reminded
and custody until February 28th look at
this beautiful woman
I can see why the you know I mean I mean
that is the face of a woman yeah that is
the face of femininity exactly wouldn't
you love to wake up next to that in the
morning absolutely as many women have
yeah look at him I'm sorry what [__]
actually take that back that's not
transphobic because I'm referring to
that person who is you're dead you're
dead pronanning this beautiful woman
exactly stunning and brave woman yeah
he's breaking boundaries yeah in terms
of sexual assault anyway yeah exactly
and by having those are very feminine
tattoos you have to say I mean it's like
a little dragon on your lower ankle yeah
like a little butterfly a little
butterfly on the shoulder that sort of
thing yeah look at that what woman
wouldn't tattoo some kind of creepy
tentacles on her forehead yeah
yeah it's a bigoted one exactly yeah
stunning and bright stunning and brave
well done Isla yeah carry on Anton let's
read more
convicted sex offender who was born male
was moved after beating a male in me so
wait wait wait and decide this for a
second
so what happened did I read that right
let's just read it again yeah let's just
make sure we don't slander uh scroll up
I want to get this right so Katie
dolatovsky was moved from male
accommodation to female accommodation
despite being a convicted sex offender
and the reason that she was she was
moved was that she beat a man yeah in a
prison yeah so this is a convicted sex
offender who was born male beat a man in
a male prison and the solution to that
problem was
to put him amongst women
[__] me these people are mental mate I
think I mean that's putting it moldling
me I'd say [__] deranged what what
the [__]
what is wrong with them
I think there is what is known as
drinking the Kool-Aid
I mean
uh
I I I I'm it's rare for me to be lost
for words but I am lost for words well
that's because you're transphobic
because if trans women are women then
the only solution we know they are and
we know they are then then obviously the
only solution when a trans woman commits
a crime yeah
is to put them in a women's prison no no
no no you put them in a male prison and
when they establish that they are
particularly violent and capable of
beating up a man yeah that's when you
put them in a women's person exactly
exactly you've got to make sure yeah
first of all that she's capable of
exerting physical violence yeah then you
put her yeah where she belongs in a
women's prison with vulnerable women
exactly
that's progress
I mean that is progress that is progress
and if you don't like it
we're going to put you in prison for
[__] hate speech mate exactly
now identify your gender and choose
which prison you want
right
do you know
I don't know what's going on anymore no
I'm kind of confused about this
um
what do you guys think
should we be putting men who beat up
other men in women's prison who was
convicted sex offenders I mean I don't
know where you guys are I mean maybe we
should do a poll yeah
should violent sex offenders who beat up
men be put in women's prison and assault
women and assault women I mean should
they be in a woman's prison
yeah it will be you know 52-48
castration seems to be high on the list
for some people yeah well I mean that is
part of the transition so is that wrong
I mean ebl prefers the wood chipper
really yeah no wood chipper well there
we go I mean look
we need to have these debates
do you know what I did say to them on
question time last night which will I'm
sure we'll talk about uh why don't we
talk about the story and they said we
don't have an lgbtq person on the panel
so we can't talk about it yeah it ain't
quite right because you only but well
but why don't you want women talking
about well I mean talk about anything
really oh mine they're just in a bang on
mate you know what I mean they're just
gonna do that yeah and then before you
know it the [__] the hours gone and
question time's over exactly and they're
just talking about what biscuits they
want
no that's you mate yeah
you talk about biscuits they talk about
all all about who's pissed them off yeah
exactly
Nate
this is kind of bad I mean I mean we
joke about it obviously yeah but it's
not good is it oh no I wouldn't say it's
a positive movement
no it's not mine it's not a step in the
right direction